This is the strength test.
I'll be testing the strength
and durability of your bayonets
by stabbing them into these
fuel cans three times.
Lyle, you're up first.
I'm ready.
I was wondering what the
gas tanks were going to be,
and now I see.
These look like some tough
gas tanks to penetrate.
Well, Lyle, your
initial fitout was great,
and everything held
together on this.
There was no issue with
reattaching it, very solid.
Overall, you made a bayonet.
Well done.
Thank you.
Scott, you're up next.
You ready?
Don't break it.
I had difficulty getting my
bayonet attached to the rifle,
so hopefully it
will be good enough.
Well, Scott, you just
barely have it fitting here.
It is a design problem,
but it is attached enough.
I feel like it's
still safe to test.
Scott, I think your
guard has loosened
a little bit right here because
of the way you had designed it.
It didn't fit properly.
So there is a little bit of
a-- a little wiggle in it.
Overall, it still functioned.
Thank you.
Matt, you ready?
No.
We're going to do it anyway.
All right.
Wow.
It was a big relief to see
the blade stab through like it
was supposed to do.
Well, Matt, not too bad.
Probably had the loosest
fit of all of the bayonets,
but your blade pierced
into the can very easily.
Well done.
Thank you.
Next step is the
sharpness test.
For that, I'm going to
turn you over to Doug.
This is the sharpness test.
To test the edge
of your blade, I
will take your detached
bayonet and I will attempt
to slice across this fish.
If your blades are sharp,
it should cut through.
Lyle, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm ready.
I've never tried to cut a
fish, other than to fillet one.
I'm so nervous right now.
OK, Lyle, the
design of your guard
did actually get in the way.
However, parts of
your edge over here
did make contact with the fish--
it just didn't lacerate.
Scott, you're up next.
You ready?
Ready.
I'm extremely nervous
about this slicing test.
I'm not sure if it's
going to quite do it.
OK, Scott, the one thing
that I'm having an issue
here is the lug that
you have, trying to get
a good, comfortable feel.
It wants to turn the blade out.
What it did was it bruised
it on the initial cut,
and then lacerated
toward the end.
So that's telling me that this
is not a very sharp blade.
Matt, you're up next.
You ready?
Let's do it.
There's still the
issue of the handle.
Even though he's slicing fish,
you're still going to put
some good leverage on there.
I pray it all works out.
OK, Matt, very light
blade, so the mass
is not there to lacerate
all the way through.
But as you can see, you
definitely lacerated.
It's a sharp blade.
It will cut.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, the judges have
made their final decision.
It's time for one of
you to leave the forge.
Scott, your blade
did not make the cut.
Dave will explain.
Scott, historically,
a bayonet that
was a soldier's backup weapon.
It had to be fully functional,
both on and off the rifle.
Due to the positioning of
the lug on your bayonet,
we couldn't get it to
fully affix to the rifle.
And when it was in your
hand, it actually wound
up digging into your palm.
Scott, please
surrender your weapon.
My experience here was
a wonderful experience.
If I had to do it
again, I probably
would have paid
attention to fitting
the lug a little bit better.
But if I can give someone
encouragement to go out and try
something, even if they've
never done it, you know,
you can make it.